josefsson herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ich bin heute wieder krieg
es wird in zukunft ein bisschen mehr
abwechslung geben ich habe mir einige
video ideen aufgeschrieben unter anderem
wird auch bald mal ein video mit justin
kommt mit pixel wolf habe heute meine
jobs hilft wenn ich hab letztens wieder
die kommentare gecheckt und da war
einiges geiles dabei zum beispiel
hiervon es heißt der und blu rays
schreibt hsg und alle anderen die diese
jobs spielmaterial blatt papier stift um
webcam und es schlägt vor dass wir bevor
wir eine kiste öffnen ein item malen
müssen von dem wir denken dass es in der
kiste drin ist und was er nicht dazu
geschrieben hat was ich mir denke ist
dass wir wenn wir das item richtig
gemalt haben
das richtige alter gemalt haben und
thomas aus der kiste nehmen dürfen haben
wir das falsche item gemalt dann fallen
wir runter an der stelle wo man
eigentlich gar nicht unter fallen kann
dann dürfen wir natürlich die kiste
nicht bluten hat mit gefallen also
bremst das unseres gestrige video
geschrieben kommt ist dankeschön für die
idee brems finde ich cool und wir
probieren das jetzt außer hier ist die
erste kiste was könnte drin sein okay ja
ich schon wieder vier papier stift alles
am start
ihr müsst wissen nicht mal so schlecht
wie wahrscheinlich die person die am
schlechtesten mal von allen menschen auf
der ganzen welt
check hier mit grünem fall sogar wenn
die grüne feinem video mixa bastert das
ist ein keks jetzt guck mal da kriegst
du bist nein natürlich nicht
dankeschön youtube dankeschön minecraft
dankeschön party für die unterstützung
ich setze mich hierhin malen keks ganz
ehrlich aber kiste nummer 2 ist da und
wisst ihr was ich kann nur eine einzige
sache mal ganz ehrlich ich glaube
einfach noch mal ist es ein krieg sein
ich hab nix aber neu gemalt ihr seht es
kein grüner pfeil dabei ist eine neue
zeichnung wir gucken xxx xxx ja wohl
egal da ist der keks ich kenne ich doch
aus ja ich will
sich zum ersten mal leute ganz ehrlich
ich weiß natürlich dass er extrem ist
einer der beiden kisten muss der
berüchtigte keks drin sein
und jetzt guck mal hier was hier drin
ist oder dritte kiste
ok ok medien diesmal auch so scheiße mal
wo ich weiß ja aber bitte hält mich
nicht dafür ja bitte nicht das finde ich
gar nicht so scheiße ehrlich gesagt es
für mich gar nicht so schwester sonja
sagt dass er seine gold hose vollständig
mittelstand und ich hoffe es in wollte
mir drin und fakten ein shetland ok
weitergeht sagt zack zack zack schnell
schnell schnell das zeichen dauert
natürlich eine ewigkeit wie er selbst
merkt dementsprechend wird ziemlich
schwierig hier relativ weit zu kommen
weil alle anderen schön gas geben
leute ich finde ganz ehrlich ich finde
so unter zeitdruck mache ich gar nicht
so scheiße ohne witz so alles klar
ich kann eigentlich gar nicht zeichnen
aber unter zeit und geht das halbwegs
seht ihr das hier
ich vermute dass in dieser kiste ein
gold schwert drin ist und jetzt 18 grad
bitte bitte in gold stellt bitte nein oh
mann oh mann oh mann alter schwede kommt
locker wie kommen maximal vier kisten
weil wir da vorne um seinen flotten
zeitgenossen haben beziehungsweise vier
kisten haben wir schon von den düften
wir eine minuten alles klar
eine einzelne knoten und jetzt brauchen
noch okay da vorne ist wieder eine wisst
ihr was ich nehme auch mal das ja ich
nehme noch mal dass ich sag es muss doch
einen gold wert sein
wir drücken jetzt mal ein auge zu weil
die anderen schon so weit sind und und
und und nein als ob in dem einfach noch
keine einzige waffe bekommen bisher
wir hatten keine einzige waffe ne kiste
glaube ich oder ich glaube nicht kratzen
wir haben jetzt schon fünf kisten
geläutet wenn man dann natürlich zweimal
auf den goldwert setzt ist man
entsprechend gelacht und sterne
der nächste ist nicht meine beste
zeichnung aller zeiten aber schaut euch
das an hier
das soll eine chain hose sein ich glaube
hier ist ein schamloser drin
bitte bitte sonst muss ich mit viel
leder und holz axe instinct gehen okay
okay alles klar dass glücklichen heute
nicht heute alles fucking klar okay der
provinz arbeiter besucher fällt aber
zunächst ein kissen zu kommen er da
vorne ist kurz davor zu finden
vielleicht ist aber das letzte modul
bisschen schwierig und hat ein bisschen
probleme aber krass das glück ist uns
bisher so was von überhaupt nicht weiter
vorne sind die nächste kiste sehr leicht
zu erreichen
okay okay okay ich hab mir dass die
sache ist man kann die materialien halt
nicht malen versteht was ich meine
also ich kann nicht mal das ding jetzt
aus gold ist oder sowie durch das malen
deswegen schreibe ich den materialien
immer so an den rand dazu sollte eine
passende hier seht ihr es sieht jetzt
seht ihr es ein stein schwert müssen
diese gast sein
bitte bitte minecraft einfach schon
bitte bitte jawohl jetzt gold und alles
klar alles klar das spiel mich wachsen
das spiel will mich einfach flachsen
jiji und jetzt gehts mit dem was wir
jetzt haben uns ins deathmatch
voll leder wirklich wirklich ja ach du
scheiße unser ziel das auch noch mega
dunkel daraus machen
ich mache daraus wir haben ungefähr 900
chancen aber wir können jetzt
theoretisch mit den dingen die wir jetzt
hier schon gemalt haben
mein gott wir haben kiel gemacht gibt es
das ja wohl noch junge zweig in
treatment what the [ __ ] und wenn jetzt
nämlich eine kiste finden dann würde ich
sagen dann ziehe ich einfach einer von
den karten ich hatte ihm gemalt ab und
fiel dann das radio spielt quasi noch
weiter mit den karten nur dass sie jetzt
nicht mehr malen muss sondern die neue
habe und jetzt haben wir probleme gingen
hier natürlich auch keine ange ja ok
kraski gut da hat es nicht gereicht aber
er hat ein holzschwert habe ich habe ich
ein holzschwert gemalt ich muss gleich
gucken welche karte ich ziehe wenn ich
dann am ende gegen die kämpfe ob das
überhaupt noch leben gerade ist einfach
es ist ein wunder ganz etwas kann man
einfach nicht anders formulieren jetzt
anpacken wunder freund roger easyjet wir
leben hat er noch okay hatte noch mehr
als 1 aber wenn kiel gemacht werden
dritter wer ganz ehrlich wer hätte
gedacht dass wir mit diesen dingen die
drei kids machen
und das gute ist wir haben ja noch
halbwegs gut und passt auf wir ziehen
unser op rüstungsteile an
scheiß auf die leder boots wir können
sie gold stiefel fucking ob blond ob
immer eine waffe dank geil hatte die
halle die gratis gekriegt hat seine
waffe gekriegt rockt egal so oder so
also auf solche aktion war ich jetzt bei
der planung der challenge nicht wirklich
vorbereitet
ich bin gerade ein bisschen überfordert
hiervon keine ahnung ja was machen wir
jetzt wieder auch erstmal merkwürdig sei
auf jeden fall alle anderen haben
einfach ein leben heißt wir jetzt einen
von den kehlen können die förster ist
bei uns fällt es bei uns ja wie sie ja
wohl und und gold wo sich sagt gold hose
wo ich sage keine volkes in seiner kiste
hat er nicht steht und wieder auf uns
nichts herausnehmen mist aber wir haben
leute wir haben nicht jemand gekippt
haben sogar jemanden rausgeschmissen und
wir stehen gerade so kurz davor mit
diesem ruhigen equipment und zwei
verbleibenden leben hier die runde zu
gewinnen bzw
zwischen uns steht halt noch der gegner
ich weiß nicht was er hat aber wir
können es theoretisch schaffen was für
eine challenge war das wort mag ja alles
klar
eclipse kann man hier irgendwie
runterschauen kommen wir irgendwelche
klippen wo man gegner runter hauen kann
wie soll ich das schaffen der typ hatte
fakten jo alter ich habe sowas von gar
keine chance
alles klar
ja alles okay gut water fakten geht und
sogar noch besser gerettet man kann also
wenig machen hier mit solchem equipment
aber während es bisher saugen geschafft
das dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen
ich will eigentlich die web suche nach
so einer klippe wo man die gegner
darunter schlagen kann ok geht da lang
ich glaube die sind nämlich überall
unsichtbare blöcke am rand das könnte
kurz mal abstecken
hier lassen sich beide blöcke hier
sollen sich beide blöcke überall uns bei
alter schwerer second uns oh mein gott
oh mein gott bin ich bitte nicht töten
okay da fühlt man sich bange blicke ich
mir bei unserem blog diese map ist sehr
ungerecht um ein schlechtes segment hat
und einfach nur weg nach unternommen
will
es gibt andere website kann man gegner
wirklich gut unternommen aber jack dass
hier ab und ich beide blöcke unsichtbar
bleibt überhaupt erst im alter schwede
und dafür sogar einer formellen block
und direkt ich weck dich alle
wir hatten so krass wie pech mit dem
malen aber ich fand mich trotzdem voll
witzig muss ich sein und die haben es
echt gut geschlagen haben sogar leute
rausgeworfen so mehr kunden wissen
fakten jetzt dankeschön für diese change
d blu rays oder blu-rays und wenn ihr
selbst ideen habt gerne damit ab in die
kommentare
und dann alle anderen die aufforderung
eine coole change idee seht dann leicht
die hoch damit ich dir auch sehr so
könnt ihr eigentlich auch selbst
bestimmen welche changes in den videos
drankommen das wasser war von mir bald
wie gesagt wenn ich mal wieder mit
justin mehr abwechslung auf jeden fall
wir sehen uns haut rein macht es gut und
bananen